The following content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu
PROFESSOR NELSON: So, over the
last few lectures we've worked
and struggled so formulate the
second and third laws of
thermodynamics in addition
to the first.
Last time we reach the third law
which is telling us that
we can't quite get to zero
degrees Kelvin, but that as
the temperature approaches
zero degrees Kelvin, the
absolute entropy of a pure
substance in perfect
crystalline form is zero.
And what that corresponds to,
if you recall, is the idea
that in a perfect crystal at
zero degrees Kelvin then you
have no disorder at all.
You have a perfectly
ordered system.
And in that case, the entropy
is absolutely zero.
And the bigger lesson from that
is that entropy, unlike
energy u or enthalpy H, we could
define an absolutely
number for it.
The zero of it wasn't
arbitrary.
Unlike the case for energy like
you've seen in lots and
lots of disciplines, where you
can arbitrarily set the zero
in a way that makes it
convenient for you.
Entropy really is
not like that.
There is an absolute zero of
entropy, and that's really
what we learn.
So now, now that we've got all
three of the major laws of
thermodynamics, what I want to
start in on is a discussion of
what happens spontaneously.
We've seen that in just one
specialized case so far, but
we should in a more general way
be able to tell when is a
system at equilibrium, where
there's no net change taking
place, and when is it still
undergoing spontaneous change
towards some other state,
presumably toward an
equilibrium state.
How do we tell?
So that's the topic that I'd
like to address today.
So, that's the big
question, right?
So let's say that we've got
our stuff in some state.
A, whatever it is.
And there's some other
possible state,
B, whatever it is.
And maybe if it some
well-defined
temperature and pressure.
What do we do to tell whether
that change will happen
spontaneously?
Do we calculate, you know, delta
S, delta u, delta H?
What tells us whether or
not the change happens?
Certainly in principle we know
how to calculate this and
other stuff for a change in
state of this sort, for lots
of changes of state.
But calculating it alone doesn't
necessarily tell us
whether or not it will just
happened of its own accord.
And that's the issue that we'd
like to be able to address.
Now, we have addressed
this in some cases.
So, for example, we know that
if we take, you know, gas A
and gas B with a barrier between
them, and we remove
the barrier, they're
going to mix.
And we saw that and went through
it somewhat carefully
and saw that if the system is
isolated, for that case we do
have a criterion that tells
us whether change happens
spontaneously.
Namely, it's delta S is
greater than zero.
That tells us whether the
change is spontaneous.
And we saw that in fact in this
case delta S of mixing,
we calculated it, saw
that it is positive.
So, clearly, if we remove this
barrier mixing takes place,
and obviously you know that
that happens from lots of
experience.
In general, the second law
gave us the Clausius
inequality for spontaneous
change.
Namely dS is greater than dq
over T. I suppose we could
specify the surroundings
temperature.
We saw that in general dS is
greater than or equal to dq
over T. if it's a reversible
process then the equality
holds, but if it's irreversible,
which means it
happens spontaneously, then
dS is greater than this.
Just to illustrate the kind of
issues that we're up against
here, let me just consider
a few different chemical
reactions, all of which
happen spontaneously.
So, I just want to write a few
examples down with a few
values for delta u or delta H or
delta S, and see whether we
can get any clues from
what we see.
So here are some spontaneous
chemical changes.
Here's one.
If we take hydrogen peroxide
in the liquid state, it can
break down to form
water and oxygen.
If we look at the thermodynamic
quantities, the
enthalpy and the entropy of the
reaction, what we find is
delta H is minus 209 kiloJoules
and delta S is plus
132 joules per Kelvin.
So it seems like there's a
favorable change in entropy
going this way.
That is, you've got lower energy
on the right and also
higher entropy.
Higher entropy basically
because you're forming
molecules of gas where there
weren't any before, and
there's more disorder in the gas
phase than in the liquid.
That is, the gas phase
molecules have
more freedom to roam.
Okay, that's one example.
Here's another.
Let's just take hydrogen and
nitrogen in the gas phase and
form ammonia.
Well, here we get, we find that
delta H is negative 92
kiloJoules.
Delta S is negative 198
joules per Kelvin.
This one also happens
spontaneously.
One thing that makes it pretty
clear is that certainly delta
S or the sign of
it alone is not
dictating the outcome here.
All right, here's
a third example.
Let's take salt, solid, and
dissolve it in a bunch of
liquid water.
Hopefully you've got experience
saying that this
happens, of course it does.
If we measure the
thermodynamics, we discover
that delta H is 4 kiloJoules,
plus 4 kiloJoules.
Delta S is 45 joules
per Kelvin.
So now we have a different sign
for delta H and it still
happens spontaneously.
So clearly, we've got signs and
magnitudes of delta H and
delta S, and if we wanted to
put delta u there, similar
things would happen.
They're all over the map.
And yet, these things are all
spontaneous processes.
And I didn't specify the
conditions, but if we were to
do this under ordinary chemical
conditions of some,
you'd say room temperature and
pressure, right, they all
happen spontaneously.
OK, clearly we'd be much better
off if we had some
systematic quantitative way to
tell whether something would
happen spontaneously.
In other words, we need criteria
for equilibrium under
more general conditions than the
ones that we've dealt with
so far, than the one set of
conditions that we've dealt
with so far, which is
isolated system.
Most chemical changes, most
physical changes don't happen
in isolated systems.
So let's start by writing down
our definition of equilibrium.
It's very simple.
The equilibrium state is the
one, and it's just one, in
which there are no spontaneous
changes that can take place to
any other state.
Now that's under whatever
constraints there are.
There's a box around it.
The temperature or
the pressure are
fixed, what have you.
But the point is, no spontaneous
changes can occur
to any other state.
So for example, when we remove
the barrier and the gases mix,
you know it's over.
Once the gases are mixed,
there's not going to be any
further net change
in the system.
It's at equilibrium, under the
new condition, that is with
the barrier removed.
OK, so now let's try to
formulate how to describe the
equilibrium state and what
dictates spontaneity.
So what we're going to
do is consider the
first and second laws.
So our first law, du
is dq plus dw.
And our second law, dS is
greater than dq over the
temperature of surroundings
for a change that happens
spontaneously.
And now, I want to combine
these two, which I
of course can do.
I can substitute dq from this
expression in here.
I also want to assume for our
present purposes that there's
only pressure volume work going
on, which is to say I
want to put p dV in here
minus p dV for dw.
So for combining for p V work,
what we see then is du has to
be less than T surroundings
dS minus p external dV.
Or we can rewrite this as du
plus external pressure dV
minus T surroundings dS
is less than zero.
Now this is fundamentally
important, and as you know
that means that it warrants
the exalted distinction of
being put up in colored chalk.
And, in fact, since we're going
to reuse this again and
again during today's lecture,
I'm going to put it over here
and leave it sacrosanct for
our further use. du plus p
external dV minus T
surroundings dS
is less than zero.
This Is our condition for
spontaneous change.
Now this is a really quite
useful expression.
For one thing what we have
here are all functions of
state and parameters that we can
control like temperature
and pressure.
So that's a big help.
And equilibrium happens when
there isn't any possible
change of state that
would satisfy this.
In other words, you've got your
system in some state.
You know it's in some state
A, there are some
other states around.
Here is what we calculate to
tell whether it happens
spontaneously.
So we now have a real usable
criterion to help guide our
understanding of whether things
happen by themselves of
their own accord or not.
Now, this is still a little
bit cumbersome, in part
because of the variables
involved, including S. That
is, most processes that we're
concerned with, they'll happen
with something held constant
like pressure or temperature
or maybe volume.
So this isn't the most useful
form that we can have, but
what we'll see shortly is that
from this, we can then derive
further criteria for essentially
any set of
variables or any set of external
constraints, like
constant temperature or pressure
or volume and so
forth that we might set.
And so that's what
I now want to do.
So I just want to use that again
and again, starting from
that, for various different
sorts of conditions and derive
the criterion for equilibrium
in each set of conditions.
So first, let's start with the
one that we already know, and
make sure that it still works,
starting from here, mainly our
isolated system.
So remember what that means?
It means no heat, no work.
Delta V is zero.
Delta u is zero.
So looking at this, du
is zero. dV is zero.
So all that's left is negative
T dS is less than zero.
In other words, T surrounding
dS has to be greater than
zero, and of course
temperature is always positive.
So dS for u and V fixed
is greater than zero.
All right, so that's
sounds right.
That's what we saw before.
When we have an isolated system,
the criterion that
determines whether something
happens spontaneously is the
entropy has to increase.
Now, what this means too is
if we imagine a bunch of
different states, and this is
the entropy of them, so this
could be any sort of variable
but the point is there are a
bunch of possible states around,
whichever one has the
maximum entropy, that's
the equilibrium state.
In other words, you know we've
got the two gases on either
side of that partition.
We remove the partition,
and they mix.
Well, the equilibrium state
is the one with the gases
completely mixed.
Of course there are lots of
states that would have maybe
local pockets of one substance
in excess and another
substance in excess
somewhere else.
In other words, there would be
lots of states nearby to the
equilibrium state.
That is, the chain, they could
they could be approached with
very little change from
the equilibrium state.
They aren't the equilibrium
state.
The entropy in all of those
states will be lower than the
entropy of the fully
mixed state.
So the point is, once you're
at equilibrium none of the
other states, they're
accessible, the system could
rearrange itself to form them,
but there is no accessible
state that has higher entropy
than the equilibrium state.
OK, that's our familiar
isolated system.
Now let's try moving to
unfamiliar territory and
extending what we know.
So, let's try constant
entropy and volume.
And the motivation for choosing
a pair like that is
easy to see, if we look at our
condition for spontaneous
change or general condition.
Well, entropy and volume
constant means dV and dS are
equal to zero.
What does that say?
It means du is less than zero.
That's our condition.
So we immediately get du
at constant S and V
is less than zero.
That's our condition for
spontaneous change.
In other words, if we don't have
to worry about entropy or
volume equilibrium is achieved
when energy is at a minimum.
Now this is what you learn in
elementary physics and in
mechanics, right.
You're not worried
about entropy.
So, you know, if you've got a
hill or valley and there's a
cart on wheels, it's going
to go down to the bottom.
The spontaneous change
lowers the potential
energy in that case.
So this is a simple condition
that's very familiar.
Now, the reason this condition
always holds in ordinary
mechanics is because you're
never, in that case, concerned
with a huge statistical
population of particles where
the disorder among
them is an issue.
We're not worrying then about
the fact that, well like in
the case of gas molecules
mixing, the macroscopic state
of the whole thing, all those
molecules, how many different
microscopic configurations
are there?
Remember, I mentioned then we'll
go further later on into
this, that entropy
can be related to
the extent of disorder.
That is, how many different
possible configurations of all
those molecules there would
be for a particular state.
The reason the entropy of the
mixed gases is the highest is
because that has the most
possible configurations.
If you start segregating the
gases, there are fewer
possible configurations that
the whole system can be in
because you're forcing
a particular set of
circumstances.
When you don't have to worry
about criteria like that,
ordinary, mechanical energy
rules supreme, and that's
dictating where equilibrium
lies.
But of course, most chemical and
biological systems aren't
that simple precisely because
you have to worry about many
particles and their statistics
and the way they might order
or disorder.
So, and of course, you know,
keeping entropy as a fixed
variable for a system like that
is extremely cumbersome.
As soon as you allow anything to
mix, like you might if you
want to do any chemistry,
entropy changes.
If you change the temperature
entropy changes and so on.
So let's go on.
Let's consider a few
other examples.
Let's hang on for a little
while longer to a set of
conditions where we will
maintain constant entropy,
namely constant entropy
and pressure.
So, the dS term is zero, but
the other two are not.
So, du plus p dV is
less than zero.
I can write this as d(u
+ pV) less than zero.
Normally I couldn't do that
because this term would have p
dV plus V dp, but we've
specified the pressure is
constant, so the dp
part is zero.
And this is a quantity
that you know, right?
What's u plus pV?
STUDENT: dH.
PROFESSOR NELSON: dH less
than zero, criterion for
spontaneous change.
In the case where S and
p are held constant.
Now, once again, like I
illustrated for entropy, and I
could have done the same for
energy here, you know, if we
again look at a bunch of
different states, and look at
their enthalpy, well, like
before, they'll be invariably
lots of possible states.
And now, what is this saying,
the equilibrium state is the
one with the lowest
possible enthalpy.
In the case here, that I just
illustrated with the little
cart going down the valley,
would be exactly the same with
regular energy, the equilibrium
state is one of
lowest energy, right.
And of course there are
lots of nearby states.
The cart could be a little ways
up the hill, and in this
case, it's enthalpy, but again,
there would be lots of
accessible states.
But if the system is in
equilibrium, none of those
states has lower enthalpy.
It's already in the lowest
enthalpy state.
That is the equilibrium state.
OK, well, now, let's get
to the big ones.
That is, in real life, the
variables that you'd normally
control aren't some combination
of entropy and
these variables, but really
their temperature, volume and
pressure, any couple of those,
might be what you'd really
have under experimental
control.
So now let's go to them.
Let's control T and V.
So, all right, so now
we're getting serious.
All right, well, there's our
equilibrium criterion.
We're still going back to it.
It still holds.
So we've now got the dV
part equal to zero.
So what this says is that du
minus T dS is less than zero,
and we can combine those
to say d(u - TS)
is less than zero.
And again, just like before, we
can do that although this
normally would say this has
T dS and also minus S dT.
T is fixed.
So that part is zero.
So this is really the
equivalent of this.
So when we did this here, we
conveniently found that that
quantity u plus pV is something
we know and love,
and we're familiar with it.
It's our enthalpy H. So we could
write that criterion as
dH less than zero.
So here, let's combine these
to define a new quantity.
It obviously has importance
because what it's going to say
is that that's the quantity that
defines equilibrium, that
tells us about equilibrium,
under the very important
practical constraints
of having fixed
temperature and volume.
Realistically, the more
likely constraints
than either of those.
So let's -- we'll go to a
brand new color, define
A as u minus TS.
it's called the Helmholtz
free energy.
OK, and then our criterion for
equilibrium under these
conditions is dA, V and T equal
to the temperature of
the surroundings, is
less than zero.
OK, and once again, you know
if we wanted to look at a
bunch of states that could be
accessed, well, we would find
lots of states near by,
in character to
the equilibrium state.
The one that is at equilibrium,
there is only one
macroscopic state
at equilibrium.
It has the lowest A.
In some sense, that's one reason
to associate this as a
kind of energy, just like
mechanical energy u or
enthalpy H, it's the minimum
free energy state that is the
equilibrium state under the
relevant conditions.
Now, let's take the step
to the biggest set of
conditions of all.
What is it when you run a
chemical reaction under
ordinary circumstances,
what's constant?
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR NELSON:
A little louder.
STUDENT: Pressure
and temperature.
PROFESSOR NELSON: Pressure
and temperature, right.
You're running, you're shaking
a beaker up here at room
temperature.
So let's look at that
set of conditions.
All right, there it is.
This is the condition for really
the lion's share of
chemistry, biology, and other
kinds of changes we'll be
concerned with.
So, there's our condition
for equilibrium.
We don't get to set any of
them to zero, right?
So, okay and we can handle that.
du plus p dV minus T dS
is less than zero, but we do
get to simplify in writing
this as d(u + pV - TS) is less
than zero, and just like we've
seen before, yes, this has p
dV and V dp, but the dp is
zero because we're at
constant pressure.
This has minus T dS minus S dT,
but the dT part is zero
because we're at constant
temperature.
So the result is we can combine
all of these as a
single differential, and just
like we've seen before, what
that suggests is that we define
another new quantity
given by this expression.
And that is the last one we're
going to describe.
And that is G, u plus
pV minus TS.
The Gibbs free energy.
Notice, we could also write,
let's rewrite that.
G is u plus the pV minus TS, but
u plus pV is H. So we also
can write this as H minus TS and
u minus TS is what we just
defined a minute ago as A.
So we can also write
this as A plus pV.
And the main thing of crucial
importance is what, by
defining this in the way we
have, what that's saying is
that dG at constant p and
T is less than zero.
There's our condition for
equilibrium at constant
temperature and pressure.
Boy, is that going to be
important for the whole rest
of the course.
So, and of course, I hardly need
to emphasize further, but
we could do the exact same
consideration that we have for
H and A, there's G. There's
our equilibrium state.
It's the state that has the
lowest Gibbs free energy.
All these things though
are incredibly
practical, useful criteria.
This is only defined in terms
of state functions.
And just like we saw before for
the case of entropy in an
isolated system, now we have
something we can calculate.
It's a state function, so we're
at constant temperature
and pressure, and now we want
to consider some chemical
change or a phase transition
or you name it.
Does it happen of
its own accord?
Well now we know what needs to
be calculated in order to
determine that.
So this one is so uniquely
pervasive, let's just really
explicitly write it all out.
For constant pressure and
temperature delta G is less
than zero, means A going to B
is, all right, let's consider
some process state A and state
B. If delta G is less than
zero, it happens
spontaneously.
If delta G equals zero, then
we're already in equilibrium.
And if delta G is greater
than zero, then it goes
spontaneously in the
other direction.
Any questions about
any of this?
Let me just give a couple
of examples.
If we go back to any of those
chemical reactions that I
wrote on the board before,
right, well certainly we can
calculate what delta G would
be for each one of them.
Because we know how to calculate
all the parts of it.
It's state functions, it's
composed of state functions
that we know how to calculate.
So we could tell.
When delta G is zero, you know,
it doesn't mean that
you've got all of one side,
all reactants and zero
products or all products
and zero reactants.
There is some mixture of them.
What this will tell us
is what mixture.
You know the stuff is in there
in equilibrium, you know the
hydrogen and nitrogen that
will form ammonia.
And in the end, when it's at
equilibrium, and you look and
you'd make a measurement,
right, you could do
spectroscopy.
You could easily see how much
of each thing is there.
It doesn't go all the way to
absolutely 100 percent
ammonia, zero hydrogen zero
nitrogen if they were mixed
together with the
right ratios.
Doesn't happen.
There would be some
of the reactants
and some of the products.
In the biochemical reactions
that are taking place in your
body, there is equilibrium
between a whole myriad of
reactants and products, and
thank heavens that gets
maintained.
So that's what this will guide
us through, and of course
that's incredibly, incredibly
important.
Here's another thing that's
worth thinking about.
There's a balance here between
ordinary energy or enthalpy
and entropy.
Energy means, you know, chemical
reactions happen, and
you end up with something that
might be exothermic, that is,
the products are more stable
then the reactants.
You burn methane, and it
combines with oxygen to form
water, to form CO2.
And if you work out the
energetics as we've gone with
thermochemistry, you discover
there's a huge negative delta
H. In other words, the bonds
are much stronger.
CO2 is really a stable
molecule.
Methane, there are certainly
some solid bonds there, but
breaking those to form CO2 and
water, well it's worth it,
right, energetically.
Still, the actual equilibrium
depends on entropy also, not
only on the energy.
And that's why, when I put
up those three different
reactions, and we saw the
signs could vary.
It's because there's a balance
between the two.
Energy may be favoring reaction
in one direction,
toward let's say products
that have lower energy.
But at the same time, entropy
is going to be favoring
whichever side has higher
entropy, has more disorder,
and there's a balance
that's achieved.
And that's why all those
reactions, first of all, in
some sense what I put up was
kind of a trivial statement in
actual fact saying they all
happen spontaneously, because
I didn't specify what we were
starting with exactly, what
concentrations we were
starting with.
Even something quite unfavorable
might happen at
least a little bit
spontaneously.
You'll have equilibrium.
In those cases, though, you'd
have quite a reasonable
equilibrium, spontaneously, that
is there would be a lot
of reaction that went if you
simply started under practical
conditions and let it go.
Even though the signs of the
enthalpy changed, and the
signs of the entropy changed
because it's a combination of
the two that matters.
Here's a really simple
example.
Mixing of oil and water.
You know from experience if
you've ever mixed them to make
salad dressing, they
don't mix too well.
And you may know that
if you heat them up,
they mix much better.
Why?
You know, we've done a bunch of
thermochemistry, and we've
kind of seen that the energy
of mixing, your energetics
don't change too much as a
function of temperature.
What's changing?
Why does it mix better
when you warm it up?
But, you know, looking at our
definition of Gibbs free
energy, here it is,
right, or here.
Let me just say, actually if you
calculated delta S for the
mixing as a function of
temperature, it doesn't change
all that much.
You know, the amount of disorder
upon mixing is not
really sensitive
to temperature.
What does change though?
T, and the entropy is weighted
by the temperature, so the
entropy matters more and more
the hotter it gets.
And that's consistent
with other things
that we've seen, right?
Remember the whole thing about
the perfect crystal at zero
degrees Kelvin has
zero entropy.
It's completely ordered.
Entropy doesn't matter
anymore.
It'll go to the lowest
energy state.
Raise the temperature, and now
entropy plays a bigger role.
So the point is, this balance
between energy that you could
think of as say bond energies
in chemical reactions, and
entropy that you can think of in
terms of disorder, how many
different possible combinations
or configurations
of something wrong,
will dictate where
the equilibrium lies.
And knowing now how to calculate
these free energies
especially the Helmholtz and
the Gibbs free energies,
that's what's going to guide
us in really calculating
quantitatively, OK, where
will equilibrium lie.
And before long, we'll start
in on discussing chemical
equilibrium, does deriving
where they lie phase
equilibrium?
Does stuff change phase to go
from liquid to solid and so
forth, right?
And where does that happen, at
what temperature and pressure
and so forth.
And it's always going to come
down to calculating the
appropriate free energy, and how
it changes in the process.
So this is going to be a guide
for us for essentially all
that we're going to do in
the rest of the term.